crazy risk there are some risks you
gotta take and life is all about taking
risks and what's that believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be part of your
daily success routine so today let's
learn one of the most common rules to
successful people follow take risks also
if you want to know what Elon Musk
myself Dwayne the rock Johnson and
others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below there are times
when something is important enough you
believe it enough that you do it in
spite of the fear surround yourself with
greatness
if you want to be more confident you
need to surround yourself with things
that make you feel confident my call
time is at 7 then you back your clock up
for hours and then that's when I get out
[Music]
one of those difficult choices I have
ever faced in life was was in 2008 and I
think I had like maybe thirty million
dollars left thirty or forty one dollars
left in 2008 I had two choices I could
put it all into one company and then the
other company would definitely die or
split it between the two companies and
but if I split it between two companies
then both might die and you know where
you put your blood sweat and tears into
creating something a bully something
it's like a child
and so it's like which one am I gonna
let one starve to death
I can bring myself to do it surprised I
split the money between two fortunately
thank goodness they both came through
making the transition in Hollywood
there was no blueprint before me so it
wasn't like I I can say oh there's that
other black Samoan wrestler who was like
over 6th floor and weighed whatever
pounds there was a time where I just I
was still trying to find my footing in
Hollywood so trying to understand how I
fit into this machine and I was enamored
and motivated by the opportunity to play
on a platform that I hadn't before and
coming from the world of wrestling which
was very crazy wild world of wrestling
so there was a time where I was little
concerned with how I fit in and also if
I was even going to fit in but yeah
years later I'm very fortunate to be
sitting here you know for me I took a
crazy risk you know I really did have a
perfectly good day job and I was really
going well it was going great
I are you nervous like were you really
like scared to jump in or what were you
feeling like was it scared but I had
self belief and that's what I think you
know ultimately because people knock you
down all the time and they poke holes
and they don't like this about your
business model and they don't believe in
you and you know you just have to keep
getting back up and getting back up and
getting back up and I think what got me
through was this I've never let go of my
vision it's like I just see a bull's-eye
and it might be really really far away
but I'm like going straight for it and
doing the best I can and but in the
meantime you know I'm building a really
interesting business Isaiah Berlin
famously said to understand is to
perceive patterns that's in essence what
creativity is Steve Jobs says creativity
is just connecting things but in order
to see patterns and rather in order to
recombine existing patterns into new
forms and new shapes you need to be
willing to blur the boundaries between
your thoughts right to be an
associational thinker right it's a free
style to ride a butterfly affecting
thought but again most of the time we
play it safe right we map out what we're
gonna say we pre plan what we're gonna
do we make a list we have a set of steps
we are prepared we've pre-scripted our
speech right we are responsible we're
not going into a situation blind but
again once in a while my friends we need
to be willing to make a mistake we need
to be willing to fail it is only when we
risk making a mistake that we might find
ourselves improvising inventing
innovating our way back to where we want
to get to do you understand what I'm
saying
think of this rant as a metaphor for the
creative process right I have somewhat
an idea of what I want to say right it's
related to creativity and it's related
to cognitive dissonance and being
willing to make a mistake that's all I
know then I start jamming about this and
what happens is I might lose myself in
some chain of thought right I
just kind of lose myself in the moment
the metaphor might like confound me and
before I know it I don't even remember
what I was saying but somehow that's
when the creativity kicks in because
somehow I've got to bring it back I've
got a rope it in I've got to remember
where I'm going I've got some
incoherence right in the Bardot's
between one statement and the other and
in doing so and in risking screwing up
the video and the take it is in that
risk that the courage that the
innovation that the creativity that the
original thought might emerge and
usually does and before I know it I've
landed and I feel like wow man I just
took a trip man you know I just sailed
into the great unknown and I brought it
back and here we are
that is what creativity is all about
that is the risk that is there be the
willingness to fail and make a mistake
that is crucial to the creative process
WrestleMania is the event my father
created and mortgaged everything he
owned and my mom owned to make it happen
WrestleMania one was at a turning point
in the company by the way absolutely and
it was available on closed-circuit
television which ultimately pioneered
the whole pay-per-view industry Wow
yep yeah and then we were one of the
first to launch our OTT
direct-to-consumer platform behind
Netflix and Hulu yeah so really you know
my father really is a visionary and in
terms of entrepreneurship his message is
always to take risks but take calculated
risks doing so well in IndyCar was there
any hesitation at all about moving to
NASCAR because it's very hard to see
from outside how big NASCAR is in the
USA the slight hesitation that I had was
just that when the everything was
evolving with doing NASCAR I was coming
off of my best IndyCar season Mike
finished lots of top fives I finished
fifth in the championship and it was
like mmm do I really want to like leave
this where it starts again it's like yes
start again and it trust me it's like
waste
again more than I thought it would be
but it's you know it's you know where
the race season was maybe 17 or 18 races
going to 38 so like triple the workload
but man when I first got in stock car I
loved it like I had so much fun the
first time I ever drove it I remember
hearing the the polar opposite of that
be that I remember Dario Franchitti
describing his first time in a stocker
and like he's like what am i doing and
the first time I got in stock car I'm
like I'm home the biggest risk is not
taking a risk at all I love it so many
people are so afraid to follow their
dreams to have this big idea that they
have that they want to go off and
accomplish we have this big vision for
ourselves and we're so afraid of making
the wrong decision
that we do nothing that you see this big
goal and you have three four or five
potential paths and you have limited
resources limited time limited money
limited abilities and you want to say I
need to make the perfect decision
because if I make the wrong one it all
falls apart and as a result we get
paralyzed by fear and we do nothing and
that's the biggest risk of all that's
when you see somebody else making tons
of money off your ideas that's when you
fast forward 10 years and you still
haven't done anything you're still in
the exact same position that you are now
meanwhile lots of people have taken that
idea that you had and are crushing it
and so the way to get over it is to
recognize that as soon as you get an
idea you need to find some small way to
test it and that you don't have all the
answers and that's ok and that you're
gonna figure it out along the way
don't be naive like I was to think that
you can create a business plan and it's
going to be the perfect business plan
you're gonna have all the answers
figured out and then you're just gonna
execute that business plan because as
soon as you finish writing your business
plan and you get out into the world and
you start testing your assumptions
you'll find out that you made a lot of
mistakes that a lot of what you thought
would happen didn't happen you couldn't
predict the future you couldn't predict
how customers would react you can't come
up with the perfect plan just sitting in
your apartment sitting on your couch
going to the library you have to
actually get out start talking to
customers test your assumptions that was
my biggest problem in my first business
I spent three months working on the
perfect business plan and then when I
got out to market I realized a lot of
what I thought was gonna happen
a lot of what I thought what the
reactions would be is now it actually
happened and that set me behind and so
being attached to that perfect idea
understand that that doesn't exist there
is no perfect plan there is no perfect
idea as soon as you get something in
your head as soon as you get an idea for
something to do then find some small way
to get out and start testing it find
some small way to get out and start
seeing are you getting yeses are you
getting traction do you even enjoy this
a lot of times these big goals that we
have for ourselves when you get into it
you want to be a youtuber great you
start making videos you're like yeah I
don't really like that go figure that
out as soon as possible people wait
years before they go out and try their
first attempt at it and then you realize
you know what that wasn't for me I saw I
strongly encourage you to one as soon as
you get an idea for something something
you want to test out something that you
think might work find some immediate way
to test it on a small scale don't take a
big risk
don't go mortgage your house don't go
take out a giant loan I hate spending
money telling making money find some
small way to get started and then to use
the fear of regret use that idea of that
if I don't do anything that in in 60
years you're gonna look back in your
life and say I really wish that I took
some action on it sometimes a smart
person comes in and they've already been
taught of certain ways or their minds
already been built up in a certain way
they are way way too conservative way
way too safe and in the world of
business sometimes it gets ugly you know
sometimes it gets dirty sometimes there
are some risks you got to take you just
gotta take in it's not conventional risk
it's not conventional thing that I'm
supposed to be doing this no you can't
lean oh there's some times that you got
to do some stuff that you can't read in
any book or any video some value
tainment literally there are certain
things in business that's like what do I
do in a situation like this I'm working
on a book right now I'm flying over to
New York to talk to a handful of major
publishers because they want me to
publish this book that has to do with
specifically on how to process issues
they once we learn how to process issues
but still if you're too conservative
you're gonna be toast on world of
business there's gonna be times in
business that you have to do certain
things that no one's gonna think about
but smart people typically just go to to
buy the rule is what they follow not law
not lost not regulations rule it's a
different story they're afraid of
breaking rules sometimes conservative
people do you think about the next act
do you think about I know it's also too
early to ask but do you think about
where you will be five years later
I mean I'm hopefully I will still be
working what as what where how I've
never known I'm not someone who plans my
career
I'm very instinctive I if I like
something I'd do it hence the reason I
fail a lot also because you know I I
take risks chances I don't like I mean I
it's very easy to drive career so but I
want to be able to have a path which is
mine
yeah let's clear up sometimes but it's
mine no one else did it before me it's
it's it's completely you know empty
territory till I get there it's my
footprints so I take a lot of pride in
that so I don't know where it'll be but
it'll be different I can assure you
it'll be something that would it'll be a
precedent I like setting really breaking
new ground yeah I want to do things that
people are like oh she's doing that I
look for things like that whether it's
acting producing I don't know what it'll
be me laughing I don't know
and life is all about taking risks and
the one thing I've got a little sign up
in my office that says that done is
better than perfect
and it is so difficult to make people in
the company understand that it is so
difficult if you don't take a risk you
won't make progress that's such a issue
I started I started talking to our
employees about taking thoughtful risks
and two things happen
the first thing happened was in a town
hall like this I got a question from an
employee saying will we have a seminar
to learn how to take thoughtful
crystallizer no we did your mother teach
you one time she must have that you
don't cross the road when there's a
truck coming your way next time you kind
of learn that you don't know you can run
over you got two choices
if they say you don't know a seminar to
teach you how not to take a risk or how
to take it thoughtfully you've got to
have it in your head and mind that says
that a risk reward equation makes sense
you do it in life at home you do it when
you get up it you know when you get up
from your bed you're taking a risk you
could fall off the bed you could fall in
the bathroom and enjoy yourself you
could choke on your tooth
we took a risk right so who talked to
you about that nobody did
why would I teach you in business how to
take a thoughtful risk a thoughtful risk
is a risk that doesn't always turn out
to be a loser if it does you're fired if
you make a mistake one time it's cool if
you make a mistake a second time the
same one then I have to ask how much
intelligence you have if you do it a
third time you should go do it with my
competitor yes it's actually not that
difficult to fathom it's really a very
simple rule it's common sense and that
is a it took a long time for people to
understand that and so people
conventional wisdom will drag you down
words you just have to be willing to
take these thoughtful risks and not be
not have 100 percent data every time you
just will not you will never have 100%
of the information
there is definitely an epidemic of
overprotective parenting but it's useful
to ask why and my suspicions are is that
this is driven by very fundamental
biological and cultural phenomena that
aren't generally considered in
relationship to this issue we don't have
very many children we don't have 12 you
know six of whom die
we have one or two and that makes them
very precious right
we're unwilling to take risks with them
and no wonder and then we also have them
much later in life and so like if you
have a kid when you're 18 you're still a
kid you know you're gonna go out and
have your life right because you're so
well you're in the in the height of your
exploratory you're in the height of the
exploratory part of your life
you're not gonna over protect your kid
because you're still a kid but if you're
40 and you have one child it's like all
your eggs are in one basket
and the probability that you're going to
take undue risks with that precious
person is very very low now obviously
there's some advantages to that because
great you would devote resources to your
child you know and foster their
development but the downside is that you
have every motivation to hover and maybe
you're also extraordinarily desperate as
a mother to maintain that bond with your
child because you've struggled so long
to achieve it it's highly highly
valuable
you can't take a risk well so these so
we might say well perhaps overprotective
parenting is a secondary and unintended
consequence of the birth control pill
and the fact that people now have
children later in life could easily be
you know if you have six kids it's like
what are you gonna do high helicopter
parent them it's like little yeah you're
so tired you can't even get off the
couch if you have six kids and there
they outnumber you right there raising
each other they're competing and they're
taking each other down a peg they're not
there's no overprotection there but with
it with a single child landscape or dual
child landscape
mostly a single child landscape then
you're gonna over protect and then that
ee thought starts to permeate the
schools and it starts to permeate the
higher education institutions as those
children mature and then that all
reinforces it not good it's not obvious
what to do about it either because if it
is driven by demographics and that in
that sense it's a much more intractable
problem than we think so I did some of
that in 12 rules for life you know I
said look you what you have to
understand is that you're a danger to
your children no matter what right you
can let them go out in the world and be
hurt or you can over protect them and
hurt them that way so you here's your
choice you can make your children
competent and courageous or you can make
them safe but you can't make them safe
because life isn't safe so if you
sacrifice their courage and competence
on the altar of safety then you disarm
them completely and all they can do is
pray to be protected raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people passion not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your it's
something serene if you liked this video
check out the one I made on how to stop
wasting your life away the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe I'll see you there
99.9% of the people that watch or listen
to this content are living in the middle